Bun venit înapoi la Quantum Computing in Practice. Acesta este episodul 6. Astăzi ne vom concentra pe una dintre preferatele mele
aplicații ale calculatoarelor cuantice, simularea naturii. În acest episod, vom discuta pașii necesari
pentru a face acest lucru pentru orice tip de problemă de dinamică cuantică, adică problema găsirii modului în care descrierea unui
sistem cuantic se schimbă în timp. Vom face asta mai întâi la un nivel înalt și apoi vom analiza un exemplu specific și vom parcurge
detaliile. mai precis, experimentul IBM din 2023 care a demonstrat utilitatea cuantică. Pentru o scurtă motivație la
început, una dintre cele mai cunoscute povești pe care noi, cei din domeniul calculului cuantic, o repetăm din nou și din nou,
povestea lui Richard Feynman care a susținut o prelegere la Caltech în 1959 și practic
a furnizat motivație pentru întregul domeniu timp de decenii. Discursul s-a numit „there's plenty of room at the
bottom". un titlu amuzant, dar ideea de bază era că susținea că mai există atât de multă fizică bogată de
descoperit la nivel microscopic.
Acea prelegere specifică nu a primit prea multă atenție până în anii '80, când tehnologia evoluase destul de mult. Și Feynman
și-a clarificat și rafinat mesajul în timp. S-a întors la Caltech în anii '80 și a prezentat un alt articol numit
„simulating nature with computers", în care a spus explicit că vrea să vorbească despre posibilitatea ca
o simulare exactă să existe, că calculatorul va face exact același lucru ca natura.
putând în esență să scapi de aproximările grosolane ale ceea ce se întâmplă la scară atomică și să le înlocuiești cu
calculatoare care înțeleg și folosesc fizica cuantică nu doar pentru a simula ceea ce face natura, ci pentru a o emula.
Acum, reamintește-ți graficul cronologic pe care l-am arătat într-un episod anterior. La un capăt aveam probleme ușor de
rezolvat care nu vor necesita nicio accelerare pe care calculul cuantic ar putea-o oferi. Dar la celălalt capăt avem probleme care sunt
foarte dificile și necesită mașini cuantice tolerante la erori, pe care nu le avem încă.
Din fericire, credem că există destul de multe probleme de simulare care se găsesc aici, la mijloc, adică în zona în care
putem lucra în prezent. Și există o mulțime de motive să fii entuziasmat și intrigat de această perspectivă, deoarece
simularea naturii stă la baza multor domenii de aplicare interesante. ca să enumerăm câteva. Dacă am putea mai bine
simula natura, am putea accelera descoperirea de noi materiale, crea produse farmaceutice și medicamente mai bune, sau
chiar explora noua fizică din spatele fizicii particulelor sau cosmologiei. Dar înainte ca tu sau eu sau oricine altcineva să încerce să
aplice calculul cuantic în aceste domenii interesante, pentru moment va trebui să înțeleagă pașii de bază dintr-un
flux de lucru tipic bazat pe simulare.
În primul rând, vei dori să identifici un sistem cuantic de interes. Acesta te va informa despre Hamiltonianul care guvernează
evoluția sa în timp și o descriere semnificativă a proprietăților sale de start sau starea sa.
Apoi va trebui să găsești o metodă adecvată pentru a implementa evoluția în timp a acestei stări. Cu aceste ingrediente
lămurite, pașii următori implică desfășurarea experimentului propriu-zis.
Acestea implică în general optimizarea implementării circuit a algoritmului de evoluție temporală, executarea
circuit-ului sau circuit-elor pe hardware cuantic și post-procesarea rezultatelor. Deci
putem numi pașii de bază implicați într-un experiment de simulare după cum urmează.
Identificarea Hamiltonianului sistemului, codificarea Hamiltonianului, pregătirea stării, evoluția stării,
optimizarea circuit-ului, execuția circuit-ului și post-procesarea.
Dar aceștia sunt pași destul de detaliați. Reamintește-ți că cele patru etape ale cadrului Qiskit patterns, care ne ajută
să înțelegem cum să implementăm o rutină în Qiskit sunt mapping, optimizarea circuit-ului, execuția circuit-ului și
post-procesarea. Deci acești primii patru pași de aici sunt de fapt incluși sub umbrela mapping-ului și de aceea
am dedicat un întreg episod acestei prime etape și dacă ai ratat asta te rog întoarce-te și vizionează episodul anterior.
Acum să trecem mai întâi prin ceea ce înseamnă acești pași înainte de a intra în orice cod. Deci primul lucru de bază pe care trebuie
să-l facem pentru a realiza un experiment de simulare este să identificăm Hamiltonianul care descrie sistemul. Uneori, de fapt
adesea, acestea sunt binecunoscute, alteori trebuie să-l construim din înțelegerea contribuțiilor de energie
ale subsetelor mici ale sistemului complet, ca în cazul de față, unde hi este Hamiltonianul care acționează pe unul dintre cele n subsisteme ale lui h.
Va trebui de asemenea să notăm dacă sistemul este compus din fermioni sau bozoni dacă lucrăm cu particule elementare. Apoi,
trebuie să codificăm Hamiltonianul și să-l traducem în termeni pe care calculatoarele cuantice îi pot înțelege. De multe ori,
acești Hamiltonieni vor fi compuși din particule elementare sau sisteme de spin. Dacă simulam fermioni sau bozoni,
va trebui să alegem o transformare de codificare cum ar fi Jordan-Wigner sau Bravyi-Kitaev. Aceste transformări vor
spune cum să traducem definiția Hamiltonianului scrisă în termenii componentelor originale, adică fermionii sau
bozonicii, în operatori Pauli care sunt ușor convertiți în gate-uri pe un calculator cuantic. De exemplu, transformarea Jordan-Wigner
definită aici oferă o mapare de la operatorii fermionici la operatorii Pauli. Dacă lucrăm deja cu
sisteme de spin 1/2 care sunt foarte comune, atunci suntem gata, în afara oricăror posibili coeficienți de normalizare,
și nu trebuie să folosim o schemă de codificare. Odată ce am codificat Hamiltonianul dorit în setul de
gate-uri al calculatorului cuantic, următorul pas esențial este să determinăm starea cuantică inițială adecvată de la care să începem
simularea. Această stare ar trebui în mod ideal să reflecte o semnificație fizică sau o configurație a
sistemului studiat. De exemplu, dacă ne interesează explorarea energiei stării fundamentale a unei molecule, am putea
începe cu o aproximare Hartree-Fock sau cu alta ușor de pregătit, care are o suprapunere semnificativă cu adevărata
stare fundamentală. Alegerea stării fundamentale inițiale afectează nu numai convergența algoritmilor variaționali
precum VQE, adică Variational Quantum Eigensolver, ci și acuratețea și eficiența
evoluției temporale sau a eșantionării în estimarea fazei cuantice. În esență, starea inițială servește drept
punct de lansare al calculului, pregătind terenul pentru extragerea de observabile utile despre sistemul cuantic
pe care îl modelăm. Pregătirea unei stări arbitrare de n qubit-uri unde ci sunt stările bazei computaționale și ai este
WEBVTT
coeficientul respectiv al fiecărei stări, iar condiția de normalizare 2 la n minus unu poate fi în general abordată prin
inițializarea stării cu operatorul o; starea de start ar fi starea standard de bază a tuturor zerourilor, scrisă adesea
astfel pentru simplificare. În general, aceasta necesită un număr exponențial de gate-uri C-not. De multe ori suntem
interesați de o stare inițială specifică pentru sistem și pregătirea ei poate fi implementată cu resurse rezonabile.
Stările produs, de exemplu, în care qubit-urile nu sunt întricate între ele, necesită doar operații pe un singur
qubit. Acum nu am avut de fapt ocazia să vorbim despre trotterizare
până acum, deși unii dintre voi probabil sunteți deja familiarizați cu ea. În esență, trotterizarea este o metodă de calcul al exponențierii matriceale care
folosește aproximări pentru a gestiona natura exponențială a operatorilor non-comutabili. Când doi operatori precum HA
și HB nu comută, trebuie să aplicăm un truc ingenios și să aplicăm alternativ exponențialele corespunzătoare ale
lui e la i HA și e la i HB de n
ori. Operatorii de evoluție alternantă sunt aplicați. Nu voi trece prin demonstrație aici, dar voi distribui un link
la o demonstrație simplă și elegantă în descriere. Dar concluzia principală este aceasta. Evoluția temporală este o
parte importantă a mapping-ului. Trotterizarea descompune o interacțiune continuă în pași discreti care pot
fi implementați pe un calculator cuantic. După generarea circuit-ului trotterizat, am terminat în sfârșit
pasul de mapping. Putem trece acum la optimizarea circuit-ului.
Pentru a face asta, iată ce trebuie realizat. Trebuie să existe un layout al qubit-urilor care mapează qubit-urile virtuale din
circuit-ul tău pe cele fizice de pe hardware. Acest lucru este necesar deoarece hardware-ul poate avea topologii particulare
care restricționează interacțiunea directă a qubit-urilor fizice. În timp ce implementarea unui
circuit cuantic presupune adesea capacitatea oricărui qubit de a interacționa cu orice alt qubit. Apoi trebuie să inserăm
gate-uri swap după cum este necesar pentru a ruta interacțiunile dintre qubit-urile care nu sunt conectate. Trebuie să traducem
gate-urile din circuit-ul nostru în instrucțiuni ISA (instruction set architecture)
care pot fi executate direct pe hardware. Apoi trebuie să efectuăm optimizări ale circuit-ului pentru a minimiza
adâncimea circuit-ului și numărul de gate-uri. Acest pas poate fi efectuat și pe circuit-ul virtual. Circuit-ul în care qubit-urile
nu au fost încă mapate pe o topologie de dispozitiv. Dar reamintește-ți că o mare parte din acestea se face automat în
Qiskit. Vom vedea exact cum în secțiunea următoare a acestei prelegeri. După pasul de optimizare, suntem pregătiți să rulăm
circuit-ul folosind o primitivă. Pentru majoritatea experimentelor de simulare, ești interesat să înțelegi schimbarea
anumitor proprietăți ale sistemului în timp. Deci probabil vei folosi primitiva estimator, deoarece aceasta
îți permite să măsori valorile de așteptare ale observabilelor corespunzătoare unor proprietăți specifice. Apoi vom
configura cele mai bune opțiuni pentru estimator, care pot adăuga tehnici de suprimare și atenuare a erorilor. În final, vom rula
experimentul. Ultimul pas este post-procesarea tuturor datelor. Aceasta extrage valorile de așteptare măsurate sau, dacă
folosești sampler-ul, distribuția de probabilitate eșantionată în baza computațională. Dacă tot ce ai nevoie
sunt valorile de așteptare ale observabilelor de interes, acestea pot fi obținute direct din primitiva estimator
atât în valorile lor brute cât și în cele atenuate față de erori. De multe ori, valorile de așteptare măsurate vor fi folosite
pentru alte calcule pentru alte cantități de interes care nu necesită calcul cuantic și pot fi
calculate pe un calculator clasic.
Acum vom parcurge un exemplu real dintr-un articol foarte influent publicat de IBM acum câțiva ani, numit
„evidence for utility of quantum computing before fault tolerance". Acum, acest articol pe care îl abreviem cu drag drept
„the utility paper" a devenit un articol foarte influent în domeniul calculului cuantic aproape imediat după publicare.
Teza generală a articolului este că un calculator cuantic zgomotos a produs rezultate exacte sau valori de așteptare
folosind 127 de qubit-uri și 2.880 de gate-uri, depășind capacitățile calculului
brut, care este simularea exactă a circuit-elor cuantice executate de hardware. Această lucrare
a fost de asemenea importantă deoarece a arătat că un calculator cuantic poate fi folosit pentru a verifica sau compara rezultate cu alte
metode clasice aproximative pentru simulări cuantice, cum ar fi algoritmii de rețele tensoriale, unde soluția
nu era cunoscută a priori. Ceea ce este de asemenea destul de interesant este că acum alții, folosind sistemele IBM quantum pe
cloud și Qiskit, pot duplica și verifica ei înșiși aceste rezultate.
Te voi ghida prin cum să faci exact asta. Deci pentru acest exemplu, vom fi un pic mai specifici despre
pașii implicați în maparea acestei probleme în intrări care pot fi înțelese de un dispozitiv cuantic. În acest caz, vom
simula dinamica magnetizării totale a unui sistem de spinuri de dipoli magnetici pe o rețea în
prezența unui câmp magnetic extern. Sistemul poate fi descris printr-un model Ising cu câmp magnetic transversal.
Modelăm aceasta cu un circuit cuantic parametrizat în care parametrii corespund valorii reglabile a
interacțiunii spin-spin sau Z și intensității câmpului magnetic X. Acum,
această serie se numește „quantum computing in practice". Deci vom discuta și procedurile din acest experiment
pe care le vom implementa pentru a face rezultatele cât mai bune posibil. Deci în continuare vom discuta cum să eliminăm
qubit-urile proaste sau qubit-urile cu fidelități reduse ale gate-urilor sau timpi de decoerență care ar putea afecta drastic
rezultatele experimentale. Aceste qubit-uri proaste pot apărea din cauza unei calibrări anterioare defectuoase
sau a sistemelor cu două niveluri care interacționează cu qubit-ul. Eliminarea unor qubit-uri din topologia nativă a hardware-ului corespunde cu
considerarea unui sistem pe o rețea descrisă de topologia rezultantă. Vom discuta de asemenea despre crearea
circuit-ului cuantic parametrizat care implementează evoluția temporală a sistemului prin trotterizare.
În acest scop, va fi important să identificăm straturile de întrăcare, care sunt o parte critică pentru principala tehnică de
atenuare a erorilor pe care o vom folosi mai târziu. Deci în acest moment vreau să mă asigur că tu, publicul, știi
că poți urmări tot ceea ce urmează să discut în tutorialul din link-ul de mai jos și pe platforma IBM
WEBVTT
quantum learning. În acest tutorial, ce s-ar putea să observi este că am creat o serie de funcții auxiliare
devreme în notebook, pe care le putem apela mai târziu pentru a ne ușura viața. Vreau să le menționez
acum, nu pentru că fac parte din procesul oficial sau formal, ci pentru că acesta este adesea ceea ce fac experimentaliștii
în viața reală pentru a-i ajuta să ruleze aceste tipuri de experimente. Și ne arată și cum vom descompune
problema noastră și mai mult. Funcțiile pe care le definim în notebook sunt următoarele. Remove qubit couplings.
Define qubit couplings. Construct the layer couplings. Construct entangling layers. Și în final, define trotterized
circuit. Să vorbim acum despre layer couplings, care ajută la definirea modului în care qubit-urile
interacționează cu vecinii lor în timpul simulării. Dispozitivele noastre cuantice folosesc ceva numit layout-ul heavy hexagonal,
un tipar special pentru conectarea qubit-urilor. În acest layout, putem grupa conexiunile numite muchii în trei
seturi separate, unde nicio două conexiuni din același set nu împart un qubit. Acesta este
un lucru important deoarece pe un calculator cuantic real nu putem rula gate-uri pe două qubit-uri în același timp dacă implică
același qubit. Fiecare qubit poate fi implicat în un singur gate la un moment dat. Prin
împărțirea tuturor conexiunilor în trei straturi, putem aplica gate-uri pe două qubit-uri pe întreg dispozitivul în trei
runde, asigurând că niciun qubit nu este folosit în mai mult de un gate pe strat. Aceste
gate-uri implementează interacțiunea ZZ din modelul Ising și sunt repetate la fiecare pas al simulării, numit
pasul Trotter. Twirling-ul modifică zgomotul din dispozitiv astfel încât chiar și un model simplu de zgomot
este probabil să fie precis. Aceasta face posibilă și învățarea precisă a modelului de zgomot și utilizarea
informațiilor obținute în tehnicile de atenuare a erorilor.
Apoi, trebuie să eliminăm qubit-urile proaste din lista noastră posibilă de qubit-uri fizice pe care le putem folosi pentru
experiment. Cum am spus, un qubit poate deveni prost din diverse motive. Uneori este doar o
calibrare proastă, o simplă greșeală care poate fi rezolvată prin simpla recalibrare.
Uneori este un pic mai complicat și legat de ceva ce numim TLS, adică un defect interfacial cu două niveluri
care duce la fluctuații ale parametrilor qubit-ului și relaxare. Acesta poate fi
rezolvat prin încălzirea întregului sistem puțin și apoi răcirea lui din nou. Dar asta durează ceva timp și nu este posibil să
se facă prin cloud. Deci deocamdată, cel mai ușor lucru de făcut este să le excluzi pur și simplu din lista de qubit-uri fizice posibile
pe care le vom folosi. Poți identifica cu ușurință care qubit-uri nu se comportă conform așteptărilor din platforma IBM quantum.
Poți reprezenta grafic caracteristicile qubit-ului acolo în platformă sau să le descarci ca CSV. Apoi creezi o listă cu toate
qubit-urile pe care vrei să le excluzi și pur și simplu le elimini din lista de qubit-uri fizice totale de pe dispozitiv.
Bine. Acum să continuăm cu pasul nostru de mapping și să generăm circuit-ul nostru trotterizat. Acum, după cum am arătat
anterior, trotterizarea discretizează evoluția temporală într-o serie de pași și trebuie să decidem câți pași.
Vom alege șase aici. Dar în general strategia este de a echilibra ceva numit eroarea Trotter, care este o
eroare de aproximare algoritmică, cu eroarea care provine din decoerență. Mai mulți pași Trotter reduc eroarea de aproximare
dar necesită circuit-e cuantice mai adânci, care sunt mai afectate de zgomotul de decoerență. Vom defini
circuit-ul în funcție de parametrul theta, care este intensitatea câmpului magnetic extern, layer couplings și
numărul de pași și qubit-uri și desigur backend-ul dispozitivului. Din cauza
dependenței magnetizării sistemului de intensitatea câmpului magnetic extern, este interesant să
executăm simularea la diverse valori ale intensității câmpului magnetic care se traduc în unghiuri diferite de RX pe
rotația pentru RX în circuit. Acum, după ce am generat circuit-ul nostru, trecem la optimizarea sa.
Primul pas aici este să definim un pass manager. Reamintește-ți că în contextul Qiskit SDK, transpilarea se referă la
procesul de transformare a unui circuit de intrare într-o formă potrivită pentru execuție pe un dispozitiv cuantic.
Transpilarea are loc de obicei într-o secvență de pași numiți transpiler passes. Un pass manager este un obiect care
stochează o listă de transpiler passes și le poate executa pe un circuit. Creezi un pass manager inițializând un obiect
pass manager cu o listă de transpiler passes. La final, pass manager-ul nostru
va crea un circuit ISA, un circuit care trebuie scris în termenii arhitecturii setului de instrucțiuni a backend-ului,
care descrie circuit-ul și gate-urile native backend-ului, dar lipsesc informațiile de sincronizare necesare pentru rularea
circuit-ului. Acum suntem pregătiți să executăm circuit-ul nostru, care este al treilea pas din Qiskit patterns. Acum, cum am menționat, vom
folosi cu siguranță estimator-ul ca primitivă preferată pentru acest experiment, deoarece vrem să măsurăm
magnetizarea totală a sistemului, iar estimarea valorii de așteptare a observabilelor este ceea ce estimator-ul a fost
conceput să facă. În acest pas va fi de asemenea crucial să specificăm opțiunile noastre pentru atenuarea erorilor. Vom folosi extrapolarea
la zgomot zero pentru a obține cele mai bune rezultate posibile. În particular, în tutorial vei vedea că specificăm două sau mai multe
valori ale factorului de zgomot la care să evaluăm modelele extrapolate și specificăm
amplificarea probabilistă a erorilor ca opțiune de amplificare. Acum, amplificarea
probabilistă a erorilor sau PA a fost cu adevărat tehnica de atenuare a erorilor preferată aici, deoarece scalează mult
mai bine decât celelalte opțiuni. Și asta este important când lucrăm la nivelul a peste 100 de qubit-uri.
Nu în ultimul rând, rulează experimentul și va dura ceva timp să se finalizeze, dar deocamdată să referențiem datele
stocate în coadă din tutorial. Vom examina metadatele, remarcând în special gate-urile stratificate și
straturile atenuate, deoarece urmează să le folosim pentru a elimina o grămadă de erori din datele noastre brute. Suntem aproape gata
să trasăm rezultatele finale. Dar înainte de asta, să adăugăm rapid un interludiu despre ce înseamnă exact extrapolarea la
zgomot zero sau ZNE. Am acoperit-o pe scurt în episoadele anterioare, dar pentru recapitulare, extrapolarea la zgomot zero
este o tehnică de atenuare a erorilor care elimină efectele unui zgomot necunoscut în timpul execuției circuit-ului, care poate fi
scalat într-un mod cunoscut. Presupune că valorile de așteptare scalează cu zgomotul printr-o funcție cunoscută, arătată aici, unde
WEBVTT
parametrii lambda specifică intensitatea zgomotului și pot fi amplificați. Putem implementa ZNE cu următorii pași.
În primul rând, amplificăm zgomotul circuit-ului pentru mai mulți factori de zgomot. Lambda 1, lambda 2,
lambda 3, și așa mai departe. Rulăm fiecare circuit cu zgomot amplificat pentru a măsura
valoarea de așteptare a de lambda 1, a de lambda 2, și așa mai departe. Și apoi extrapolăm înapoi la limita de
zgomot zero, valoarea de așteptare a de zero.
Principala provocare în implementarea cu succes a ZNE este să ai un model precis pentru zgomotul din valoarea de așteptare
și să amplifici zgomotul într-un mod cunoscut.
Există trei modalități comune prin care amplificarea erorilor este implementată pentru ZNE: scalarea duratei pulsului prin calibrare,
repetarea gate-urilor în cicluri de identitate și adăugarea zgomotului prin eșantionarea canalelor Pauli.
Numim ultima PA. Amplificarea probabilistă a erorilor este cea mai bună alegere aici, deoarece întinderea pulsului este foarte
costisitoare din punct de vedere computațional. Plierea gate-urilor nu are garanții teoretice în conservarea biasului zgomotului. Dar PA poate fi
aplicată oricărui circuit care poate fi rulat cu factori de zgomot nativi, dar necesită învățarea modelului de zgomot. PA presupune
același model de zgomot bazat pe straturi ca anularea probabilistă a erorilor.
Totuși, evită overhead-ul de eșantionare care scalează exponențial cu zgomotul circuit-ului. Pentru a învăța modelul de zgomot,
trebuie mai întâi să identificăm straturile unice de operații pe două qubit-uri din circuit.
Pentru fiecare strat, aplicăm Pauli twirl gate-urilor pe două qubit-uri pentru a ne asigura că zgomotul este bine descris de un model de zgomot de amortizare.
Repetăm perechile identice de straturi la adâncime variabilă și în final ajustăm o fidelitate sau o eroare pentru fiecare canal de zgomot. Și
desigur, deși recomand înțelegerea acestei metode până la un anumit punct, realizarea ei manual în Qiskit este
mult mai simplă, așa cum se arată în tutorial. Acum, în final, să aruncăm o privire la datele reprezentate grafic. Linia
punctată gri arată rezultatele exacte obținute cu metode clasice aproximative cu eroare de aproximare
convergentă la un prag mic. Cum poți vedea, datele brute pentru diferiții factori de zgomot aleși la
început sunt destul de departe de această linie punctată. Linia albastră continuă arată datele ținând cont de procesarea noastră ZNE
și poți observa imediat că este mult mai aproape de rezultatele exacte.
Pe scurt, valorile zgomotoase arată o abatere mare de la valorile exacte.
Valorile atenuate sunt aproape de valorile exacte, demonstrând utilitatea tehnicii de atenuare bazate pe PA.
Și asta încheie în esență acest episod. Pentru a rezuma rapid ce am învățat, simularea cuantică este una
dintre cele mai promițătoare domenii de aplicare pe termen scurt și mediu.
Are aplicații variate, de la produse farmaceutice la fizica energiei înalte,
știința materialelor și nu numai. Articolul de utilitate de la IBM publicat în 2023 a arătat
calea spre utilizarea calculatoarelor cuantice pentru descoperirea științifică. Am parcurs
tutorialul asociat care însoțește acel articol în detaliu. Pașii pentru a rezolva o problemă de simulare de la start
până la final sunt relativ simpli, mai ales odată ce te obișnuiești cu ei. Și sper că
poți de acum înainte să folosești acest video și tutorialul ca ghid pentru și mai multe probleme de simulare în viitor.
Mulțumesc că ai urmărit și ne vedem data viitoare la Quantum Computing in Practice.